absolutely and can you tell us a little
bit about that twitter uh while i post
this red flags link here for you
i just posted it actually i figured how
to get there um
which uh twitter do you want me to hit
yeah you you post you made a
a very viral twitter post on oh yeah
you'd get a guy right i think those
seven things
yeah i'm i'm probably going to do a
video on this at some point
um how to keep a man in six
simple steps uh number one learn how to
cook amazing dishes
pretty straightforward like apply heat
to food so it tastes good like have some
culinary skills
uh number two be feminine like have long
hair makeup nails etc
because i mean we don't want to date a
guy because we're guys right exactly
number three don't nag him over trivial
stuff that seems pretty straightforward
but many women today have some
difficulty with it i mean like the whole
karen meme
is a very good example of the reach and
the acceptance that we have today of
like
nagging whiny caringy type women right
number four be debt free you think that
be an easy one like
be able to manage your money like uh
understand finances spend less than you
make save money for a rainy day but
the amount of women that have financial
issues today
is like off the chart and i think it's
one part um
you know management issues but at the
same time they don't typically choose
high paying jobs that you know come with
longer hours and more compensation
and more rewards they tend to go for the
easier stuff right which is fine
there's a wage gap yeah and then you'll
hear you know complaints about wage gap
and blah blah blah
um number five was don't be a single mom
um
again you know you'd think that there
would be some ownership taken but it's
like it's not my fault he was an [ __ ]
he's a loser like
every every day like if you guys follow
me on instagram or on twitter like i
kind of get tired of putting them out
now you know be honest with you but like
every day i get two or three dms or
emails with like a screenshot of
somebody's twitter
or certain nuts on twitter but like
tinder or like a bumble or something
like that
and it's some like 21 year old with six
kids with a bun in the oven
that thinks she's worth a million
dollars and wants like you know
everything under the sun from uh guys
but
i mean guys if you're gonna get with a
single mom you have to understand the
number one like the number one problem
is you're self-cuckling yourself i mean
you're basically raising another man's
kid
and number six was know how to please
him in bed i mean
seems like pretty straightforward this
is stuff that grandmothers would be
telling their daughters
20 30 years ago today you say [ __ ] like
this
the internet breaks bro i was on like um
i don't know
four or five different tv shows in the
news because when i searched for like
the keywords
in that tweet there was a new station
somewhere in eastern europe like uh
latvia or i don't know some somewhere in
eastern europe that covered it
australia covered it twice new zealand
covered it england covered it canada
covered it and it was covered in
the us and then it was also on the front
page of blogs everywhere
every uh feminist left leading uh
blogger did an article about some bald
man that was telling
women how to be feminine right
dude i remember reading that tweet and i
was just like
man you know what i'm saying like
someone said it bro somebody needs to
say it
somebody needs to say it man because
here's the thing bro if there's any
women watching right now all
two of you we got two or five people
watching by by the way guys don't forget
to like
comment subscribe obviously this type of
content always gets
censored some way you know i mean people
hate on guys like me and rich trying to
give you guys the truth
uh quick with the super chats i've been
kicking them uh at work with the kiddos
just want to slide through and show
love to my brother myg salute thank you
so much afi and then he goes
uh another five dollar super chat salute
to the big bro rich cooper blessings
thank you thank you
coffee um so yeah no man so like you
know
obviously like people are gonna hate
anytime you give uncomfortable truths
because it's okay for women to have
boundaries but if a guy exerts any type
of boundaries
they lose their minds which is always
hilarious nobody nobody complains when
there's women on youtube telling other
women how to like
you know milk a rich guy and be a sugar
baby
and none of that stuff that's that's
totally acceptable nobody complains
about that but
you know if you're a guy that you know
has some seasoning in his life and a
little bit of salt and pepper's beer and
you start talking to guys about
the reality of the sexual marketplace in
the world they lose their [ __ ] and it's
like
you know the louder the screech the
closer you are to the truth
absolutely man absolutely the
uncomfortable truths about female nature
are never
taken well because that's kind of how
women get over on guys like a lot of
girls bank on the fact
that you don't know your own value as a
man and they can just bamboozle you and
as i always say like a lot of chicks man
they sell purity man they're purity
dealers they come up to you and they're
like
hey i'm a good girl all this they're
just you know what i'm saying those are
the worst ones too
and it's like nah bro he's like oh i'm a
virgin you know and you're just like
the lie detective determined that was a
lie because
you'd be lying dude so they're always
trying to sell purity so when you
give these uncomfortable truths it it
ruins the game for them because they
are appearing dude it goes on through
life like 30s 40s
50s i'm sure there's like 67 year old
you know women
that are going on about their value and
their
and their purity and about how they've
done no wrong in their life and
everything wrong that came their way was
not their fault it was because of some
dumb ass guy or some loser
or something else and they want to take
zero ownership for it right
it's it's it's just like the purity
story keeps going on throughout life
trust me
you